So are you thinking about this a lot??
那么，你一直在想这个问题吗？
I got sad about it on the training again this morning. It comes at totally random moments, you know?
今天早上在火车上想起这个，我又难过了。这种感觉总是毫无预兆地突然袭来，你知道吗？
That's David Kestenbaum, one of the producers of our program. And to understand what he's been sad about, I think it's not going to make any sense unless you know that he's a physicist. He has a PhD in particle physics.
那是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆，我们节目的制作人之一。要理解他为什么难过，我觉得除非你知道他是位物理学家，否则你很难感同身受。他拥有粒子物理学博士学位。
He was on one of the teams that discovered the top quark at Fermilab back in the '90s, before he became a journalist. So he thinks like a scientist. And he recently stumbled across a story he'd never heard before about Enrico Fermi, the physicist that Fermilab is actually named for.
在成为记者之前，他曾是费米实验室90年代发现顶夸克的团队成员之一。所以，他的思维方式像个科学家。最近，他偶然听到一个关于恩里科·费米的故事，以前从未听说过，而费米实验室正是以这位物理学家的名字命名的。
So the story goes that this is 1950. Fermi's visiting Los Alamos.
故事发生在1950年。当时费米正在访问洛斯阿拉莫斯。
Los Alamos, where they developed the atomic bomb?
洛斯阿拉莫斯，就是他们研制原子弹的地方？
Yeah. And they're sitting around at lunch. It's Fermi and a handful of other physicists and they start talking about extraterrestrials.
对。他们当时正坐在一起吃午餐。费米和另外几位物理学家聊起了外星人。
One of the scientists who was there remembers that they talked about some New Yorker cartoon, which had flying saucers and cheerful aliens stealing our trash cans. They joked about it.
其中一位在场的科学家回忆说，他们当时谈到了《纽约客》上的一幅漫画，画的是飞碟和快乐的外星人偷走了我们的垃圾桶。他们对此开着玩笑。
And then out of nowhere, Fermi says something like, so where are they?
然后费米突然冒出一句：那么，他们都在哪儿呢？
Meaning?
是指？
The aliens.
外星人。
And did people know what he meant?
大家明白他的意思吗？
Yeah, somehow everybody knew exactly what he meant. The idea was basically that, like, the galaxy is this huge place, right? Hundreds of billions of stars. It's been around for billions of years. If you believe that intelligent life is something that just arises given enough time, where is everybody?
明白，不知怎么的，每个人都完全理解了他的意思。基本概念是这样的：银河系这么大，对吧？有数千亿颗恒星。它已经存在了数十亿年。如果你相信智慧生命只要有足够的时间就会产生，那么大家都在哪儿呢？
Like, there have been billions of years, where civilizations could have developed and become way more advanced than we are and traveled from star to star, sent signals or something. Where are they? If that's right, where are they?
我是说，已经有几十亿年的时间可以让文明发展并远超我们，从一颗恒星旅行到另一颗恒星，发出信号什么的。他们在哪儿？如果理论成立，他们人在哪儿呢？
This question became known as the Fermi Paradox, which goes like this. If it's so likely that intelligent life exists elsewhere, where is it? Why hasn't anybody shown up? And of course, the simple answer to that would be, well, nobody else exists.
这个问题后来被称为“费米悖论”，逻辑是这样的：如果智慧生命在其他地方存在的可能性如此之大，那它们在哪里？为什么没有人出现过？当然，最简单的答案可能是：好吧，根本没有其他生命存在。
And I had never thought-- it made me think, maybe we're alone. I really thought that for the first time. Yeah, it made me really sad.
我从未想过……这让我开始思考，也许我们是孤独的。这是我第一次真正这么想。是的，这让我感到非常难过。
I had never thought about it seriously before. I had always assumed that life was everywhere. But he's making a really serious point here. He's raising a tough question.
我以前从未认真考虑过这个问题。我一直以为生命到处都是。但他提出了一个非常严肃的观点，提出了一个尖锐的问题。
So for months now, when David's brushing his teeth or doing nothing in particular, it'll hit him again. Maybe we're alone in the universe. Like this morning, on the train.
所以这几个月来，每当大卫在刷牙或无所事事时，那种想法就会再次涌上心头。也许宇宙中只有我们。就像今天早上在火车上一样。
The specific thought I was having was that this would mean that there's nobody out there who knows more than we do, like, about science, about-- there are no better songs. There are no better books. This is it, you know?
我当时的具体想法是，这意味着外面没有任何比我们懂得更多的人，比如关于科学，关于……没有更好的歌曲，没有更好的书。这就是全部了，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like, what we know is it. What we are is it.
就像是，我们所知的这就是极限。我们的存在就是全部。
Why is your response to this sadness?
为什么你对这件事的反应是难过？
Why is your response not sadness? Of course that's sad.
为什么你的反应不是难过？这当然很让人难过。
This whole thing reminds me of just a really, really old Woody Allen movie-- it might be Annie Hall-- where there's a scene of him as a kid. And he's saying to some adult-- she's saying, why didn't you do your homework or something like that. And he's like, well, because the universe is expanding.
这整件事让我想起一部非常非常老的伍迪·艾伦电影——可能是《安妮·霍尔》——里面有一个他小时候的场景。他对着某个大人说……那人问他为什么不做家庭作业之类的，他说，因为宇宙正在膨胀。
And then the adult is like, why is that any of your business? And that's my question for you. Why is it any of your business?
然后大人问，那关你什么事？这也是我想问你的。这关你什么事？
Oh, I totally read that the other way. I was like, he's making a serious point. Why is no one listening to him?
哦，我完全理解错了。我当时觉得，他在提出一个严肃的观点。为什么没人听他说呢？
Oh.
哦。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
See, that's the problem. I'm in his shoes and I'm not making a joke. I feel like if you were able to really imagine it, it would make you sad.
看，这就是问题所在。我站在他的立场上，我可不是在开玩笑。我觉得如果你能真正想象一下，这会让你难过。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. When you look up at the stars, do you think about what they are, and the distances and stuff, and all that?
是的。当你仰望星空时，你会思考它们是什么，距离有多远之类的问题吗？
No, not in a deep way.
不，没有深入思考过。
I mean, it's so easy not to feel anything. But it's a crazy thing you're looking at, just how small we are and how big it is.
我是说，不产生任何感觉很容易。但你所看到的一切其实极其疯狂，我们是多么渺小，而它又是多么巨大。
David tried to explain the feeling that he was having to me in a bunch of different ways. And the explanation that made the most sense to me was when he told me that he'd been looking at videos with his five-year-old son, Augie, who's really into space. Videos of the Apollo moon missions, with astronauts happily bouncing around on the lunar surface and driving in that moonbuggy they had. And David found himself just looking at where they were, really looking at the moon.
大卫试着用很多种不同的方式向我解释这种感觉。而我觉得最能理解的解释是，他告诉我，他一直和五岁的儿子奥吉一起看视频，奥吉特别痴迷太空。那是阿波罗登月任务的视频，宇航员在月球表面快乐地蹦跳，开着他们那辆月球车。大卫发现自己正盯着他们所在的地方看，真正地注视着月球。
Oh, look how dead it is. There is nothing there. The moon is just this dusty, awful rock. And what if it's like that everywhere.
哦，看它是多么死寂。那里什么都没有。月球只是这块满是灰尘、可怕的岩石。如果到处都这样怎么办？
You know, liquid methane oceans and whatever rocks, but no life at all. What if that's the rest of the galaxy? Space just seemed like some horrible, awful, dangerous place to me.
你知道，有液态甲烷海洋和各种岩石，但根本没有生命。如果银河系的其他地方也是这样怎么办？太空对我来说就像一个可怕的、糟糕的、危险的地方。
I see that. There's no hope. It's just death out there.
我明白了。没有希望。外面只有死亡。
It's a lot of pressure if we're the only thing going on. It's a lonely thought.
如果我们是唯一的幸存者，那压力太大了。这真是一个孤独的想法。
I first found out that David was thinking about all this at our staff story meeting a couple of weeks ago. And I'll be honest, when he told everybody that he was upset about the Fermi Paradox, we all laughed at him. Like OK, that's what's upsetting you? Which he gets, but it doesn't help him.
我第一次发现大卫在想这些事，是在几周前我们的员工选题会上。老实说，当他告诉大家他为“费米悖论”感到不安时，我们都笑话他。心想：好吧，这就是让你难过的事？他明白我们的反应，但这对他没帮助。
I can't find anyone to really talk it through with.
我找不到任何人能真正和他深入交流。
Because none of us took it seriously?
因为我们都没当真？
Yeah. I feel like when I say it, people are like, yeah, I don't know, or I always thought that. The thing that bugs me about it is he's making a real scientific argument. I wanted to talk through the science of it with somebody. It's not just a "what do you think? I bet you they're there. I bet you they're not there." He's making up a physics point, you know?
是的。我觉得当我说出这些时，人们的反应就是：好吧，不知道，我一直都这么觉得。让我烦恼的是，他提出的是一个真正的科学论点。我想和别人讨论其中的科学原理。这不仅仅是“你怎么想？我敢打赌他们在那里，我敢打赌他们不在那里。”他是在提出一个物理学观点，你知道吗？
Well, today on our radio program, stories from the one civilization we know does exist, stories of people who head out on missions here on our own planet to vanquish their own loneliness. We hear from a 9-year-old girl, a married couple, and of course, David. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中，将讲述来自我们所知的唯一存在文明的故事，关于那些在我们自己的星球上执行任务，去克服自身孤独的人们的故事。我们将听到一个9岁女孩、一对已婚夫妇，当然，还有大卫的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
Act 1, "I Think We're Alone Now." So none of us would satisfyingly engage our coworker, David Kestenbaum, about Fermi's paradox. He needed a physicist to talk to to help him figure out what to think.
第一幕，“我想我们现在孤独了”。看来我们没谁能令人满意地与同事大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆讨论费米悖论。他需要找一位物理学家谈谈，帮他理清该怎么想。
So he went to talk to one of his old physics professors from when he got his PhD at Harvard. Her name is Melissa Franklin. Her specialty is particle physics. Here's what happened.
于是他去找了他在哈佛读博时的一位老教授。她叫梅丽莎·富兰克林，专门研究粒子物理学。结果是这样的。
I went to see Melissa because I figured for sure she would understand. When I was a student, I'd go to her with physics problems but also life problems. Arguably, this was both.
我去找梅丽莎，因为我想她肯定能理解。我做学生时，遇到物理难题甚至生活难题都会去找她。可以说，这个问题两者皆有。
So there's this thing that's been bugging me. And every time I tell people about it, they just laugh.
有一件事一直困扰着我。每次我跟别人提起，他们只会笑。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
OK, I'm laughing first.
好吧，我先笑为敬。
Do you know what the Fermi Paradox is?
你知道什么是费米悖论吗？
I told her the story about Fermi at lunch and his question, where is everybody?
我把费米午餐时的那个故事和他的问题——“大家都在哪儿呢？”——讲给她听。
We talk about these things all the time, you know, casually or just over beers or coffee and it's all a joke. But it felt really serious.
我们总是讨论这些事情，比如随口聊聊，或者喝着啤酒咖啡的时候，这一切都像是个玩笑。但这感觉真的很严肃。
I don't think-- honestly, you say that we talk about these things all the time over beer, but I don't think people actually do. They think about extraterrestrials. We think about what messages-- I've thought for hours about what messages they would send, what messages I would send, how to communicate with them. But it actually, until you walked in here today, I'd never thought maybe there weren't any.
我不觉得……老实说，你说我们经常在喝啤酒时讨论这些，但我认为人们其实并不会。他们想的是外星人。我想过好几个小时他们会发送什么信息，我会发送什么信息，如何与他们交流。但在你今天走进这儿之前，我从未想过也许根本就不存在外星人。
Honestly, I was feeling a little choked up when I got to the part about how I had been thinking we might be alone. I thought she would be sympathetic, but she kind of rolled her eyes, just like everybody else.
老实说，当我讲到我一直在想我们可能是孤独的时，我哽咽了。我以为她会同情我，但她像其他人一样翻了个白眼。
Look, I mean there's so-- look, compared to seeing all the polar bears die, this is not sad. So here, the point is there were polar bears and now there aren't any. And there, there were never anybody and we're sad. There's still nobody there!
听着，我的意思是……相比看到所有的北极熊死亡，这并不悲伤。在那边，曾经有北极熊，现在没有了。而在这边，从来就没有人，我们也感到悲伤。那儿依然谁也没有！
I guess, I get that it's a weird kind of sadness, but it's a real thing I feel.
我想，我明白这是一种奇怪的悲伤，但这确实是我真实的感受。
I know you feel that. I know. I know. I know you do feel bad, but what do you feel about the polar bears?
我知道你这么觉得。我知道。我知道你确实感到难过，但你对北极熊的处境有什么感觉？
This was something I also felt very alone in my worrying about it, you know? Yeah. I would say to my wife, you know, I was thinking again today we might be alone in the universe. And she's like, I know, sweetie.
这是我感到非常孤独的一点，没人跟我一起担心这些，你知道吗？是的。我会对妻子说，你知道，我今天又在想我们可能是宇宙中孤独的生命。她会说，我知道，亲爱的。
I know, sweetie? That's really nice.
“我知道，亲爱的”？这真是太好了。
Like, just think about it for real, like, for real. Not just as a "hey, what are the odds we're alone," or this or that. For real, because it might be true.
我是说，真正地思考一下，认真地思考。不仅仅是“嘿，我们孤独的可能性是多少”之类的。因为这可能是真的。
Yeah. Do you think it's really hard? Maybe you're just having college thoughts when you're 45.
是的。你觉得这真的很难吗？也许你只是在45岁的时候有了大学生的念头。
But then we got down to it, the thing that I'd come for. Melissa started doing this thing that I'd forgotten physicists sometimes do when you ask a question. They ask you more questions.
但随后我们切入了正题，也就是我来的目的。梅丽莎开始做我忘了物理学家在被问到问题时有时会做的事。他们会反问你更多问题。
What exactly do you mean by being alone? Let's properly define the question here. You're talking about no intelligent life or no life at all? What if there's one crappy plant on another planet? How would you feel about that? What if advanced life like us is just a mathematical improbability, a total fluke?
你所说的孤独到底是什么意思？让我们正确地定义这个问题。你指的是没有智慧生命，还是根本没有生命？如果另一颗星球上只有一株烂植物呢？你会有什么感觉？如果像我们这样的高级生命只是一个数学上的极小概率，是一个彻底的侥幸呢？
And then you would say, OK, if that's the case, I have to believe in God. So that's what you're saying.
然后你会说，好吧，如果真是这样，我必须相信上帝。所以这就是你要说的吗？
How many physicists do you know who believe in God?
你认识多少相信上帝的物理学家？
Six.
六个。
I don't think Fermi thought we were alone. And Melissa didn't think we were alone either. Come on, she said. There are lots of possible explanations for why we haven't found intelligent life. It doesn't have to be that we're alone. She ran through some of them with me.
我不认为费米觉得我们是孤独的。梅丽莎也不认为我们是孤独的。她说：“得了吧，我们没发现智慧生命的原因有很多，不一定是因为我们孤独。”她跟我列举了其中的一些可能。
OK, here we go.
好吧，开始吧。
There are lists of them online that scientists and other people have come up with. I have to say, they were not encouraging. For example, maybe other life has arisen, but just not intelligent life. In other words, there are microbes but nothing else, which would be a bummer. The next one's a bummer, too.
网上有科学家和其他人整理的列表。我必须说，这些都不太令人振奋。例如，也许确实出现了生命，但不是智慧生命。换句话说，只有微生物，而没有别的，这会让人很失望。下一个也让人失望。
It's the nature of intelligent life to destroy itself. That's really sad. If that was the reason, that would be really sad.
智慧生命的本质就是自我毁灭。这真的很悲伤。如果是这个原因，那会非常悲伤。
Let me remind you that Fermi, when he asked this question, was at Los Alamos. They just built the first atomic bombs. They were about to build the first hydrogen bombs, which would be thousands of times more powerful. That leads us nicely to the next possibility.
提醒你一下，费米提问时是在洛斯阿拉莫斯。他们刚造出第一批原子弹。他们正要制造威力大上千倍的氢弹。这正好引出了下一个可能性。
It is the nature of intelligent life to destroy others. That would also be sad.
智慧生命的本质是毁灭同类。那也会很悲伤。
Another possible explanation was called the Inflation Hypothesis and the Youngness Argument. Neither of us could understand the physics of that one. Something to do with synchronous gauge probability distribution. This one made sense, though.
另一个可能的解释叫“暴胀假说”和“年轻论”。我们俩都理解不了其中的物理原理。大概和同步规范概率分布有关。不过这个解释说得通：
Everyone is listening. No one is transmitting. Yeah, I guess it takes less energy to listen than to transmit.
每个人都在听，没人传信号。好吧，我猜监听确实比发送信号耗能少。
Oh, that's a good point.
哦，这点说得对。
Yeah.
是的。
Then there was the zoo hypothesis. Basically, that aliens have left us alone undisturbed as a kind of intergalactic nature preserve. Or this one, aliens are here right now, we just haven't figured it out. Melissa liked that one.
还有“动物园假说”。基本上是说，外星人为了把我们当成星际自然保护区，所以让我们不受干扰。或者这个：外星人现在就在这儿，只是我们没发现。梅丽莎喜欢这个说法。
I mean, how would we know if cockroaches were alien or not?
我是说，蟑螂是不是外星人，我们怎么知道呢？
I mean, they have DNA. They seem very much like part of our family tree.
我是说，它们有DNA。它们看起来非常像是我们进化树的一部分。
But maybe they make themselves seem like our family tree in order to live here. Because how could they live here if they weren't?
但也许它们伪装成了我们进化树的一部分以便居住在这儿。因为如果不是，它们怎么能待在这儿呢？
Be serious for a second.
认真一点行吗？
I can't believe that you get to decide what's serious. You are so, so wrong! You go, oh, oh, stop. Oh, don't be silly.
真不敢相信你居然能决定什么是严肃的。你错得太离谱了！你竟然说：“哦，停下。别傻了。”
And you're the one bringing up the crazy things, like you're going to cry because there's no extraterrestrial intelligence. Jesus. OK.
结果你自己才是在谈论疯狂的东西，比如你会因为没有地外智慧生命而哭泣。天呐，好吧。
Let's go talk to Paul. I need to talk to Paul. I want to ask him now.
我们去找保罗吧。我得和保罗谈谈。我现在想问他。
OK.
好吧。
Paul is Paul Horowitz. He's also a professor here, and conveniently, one of the pioneers behind the search for extraterrestrial life. He's been at it for decades.
保罗是保罗·霍洛维茨。他也是这里的教授，而且方便的是，他是搜寻地外生命的先驱之一。他已经研究这事几十年了。
He did one of the early searches for extraterrestrial signals at the giant Arecibo Observatory. There is a photo of him and Carl Sagan and Steven Spielberg-- you know, Close Encounters, ET-- throwing the on switch for another telescope search for signals from other worlds. I know Paul because he taught one of my classes way back. He's 74 years old now.
他曾在巨大的阿雷西博天文台进行过早期的地外信号搜寻。有一张他和卡尔·萨根以及史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格（你知道的，《第三类接触》、《E.T.外星人》导演）合影的照片，他们正在按下另一个搜寻外星信号的望远镜的启动开关。我认识保罗是因为我以前上过他的课。他现在74岁了。
Paul we need your help.
保罗，我们需要你的帮助。
Paul, David Kestenbaum.
保罗，这是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
你好，你好。
How are you doing?
你好吗？
I hadn't reached out to Paul originally because, honestly, I was intimidated. I was upset about the Fermi Paradox? I figured he'd think that was silly. But now here we were.
我起初没找保罗，因为老实说，我有点畏惧。我为“费米悖论”感到不安？我以为他会觉得这很蠢。但现在我们在这儿了。
And it crossed my mind for the first time that we might be alone. And it made me really sad. That felt like a real thing.
我第一次想到我们可能是孤独的。这让我非常难过。这感觉像是一个真实的问题。
Yeah.
是的。
Did you ever go through anything like that?
你经历过这种感觉吗？
No, because I don't think we're alone.
没有，因为我不认为我们是孤独的。
You don't?
你不这么认为？
No, I think-- I think the Fermi Paradox is a serious question.
不，我认为费米悖论是一个严肃的问题。
Yeah.
是的。
I think there's probably some good answers. The unbounded time is a problem.
我认为可能有一些很好的答案。无限的时间是个难题。
Maybe, he says, civilizations don't last long enough to figure out how to travel between stars. Maybe they last 10,000 years or 100,000 years. And maybe traveling through space is just too onerous, the vast distances.
他说，也许文明存在的寿命不够长，不足以搞清楚如何进行星际旅行。也许它们只能存在一万年或十万年。而且也许太空旅行负担太重了，距离太遥远了。
Which is sad in its own way. But--
这本身就很悲伤。但是……
Maybe civilizations live long enough to communicate with each other, he says. In which case, we could hear from them. We haven't been listening that long, just a few decades.
他说，也许文明存续的时间足够长到能互相交流。在这种情况下，我们就能听到它们。我们监听的时间还不够长，才几十年而已。
And who knows? We may not be looking in the right way. Paul's been thinking about that problem.
谁知道呢？也许我们搜寻的方式不对。保罗一直在思考这个问题。
It's interesting, because just as you walked in, I'm working on a new scheme to do the entire sky all the time looking for optical pulses. But you cannot dismiss the Fermi Paradox.
真有意思，因为就在你走进来的时候，我正在研究一种新方案，打算一直监测整个天空寻找光脉冲。但你无法忽视费米悖论。
Yeah.
是的。
The best you could do is squirm, and wave your hands, and say there are some ways for you not to be sad.
你所能做的最好的事就是扭动一下，挥挥手，说还是有些方法让你不必感到难过。
Are there any physics things that make you sad like that?
有什么物理学上的事会让你感到这种悲伤吗？
Well, what really bothers me is, what happens after you're dead? Is it just like they switch off the light and there's never anything ever, ever again that you experience? Can that really be?
嗯，真正困扰我的是，死后会发生什么？是不是就像灯被关掉，你再也不会有任何体验了？真的会这样吗？
This was not a physics problem, per se, though it is a problem. And you can think about it like a physicist.
这本身不是一个物理学问题，虽然它确实是个难题。你可以像物理学家一样思考它。
I suppose there's some precedent for it. Because before you were born, you know, there was nothing, right? But I have a hard time wrapping my mind around being dead. And this probably becomes more of a problem when you get old, because you realize it's actually going to happen. That bothers me a lot more than the possibility that there's not other civilizations out there doing whatever they do.
我想这有些前例。因为在你出生前，你知道，什么都没有，对吧？但我很难想象死后的状态。这在你变老时可能会变成更大的问题，因为你意识到它确实会发生。这比没有外星文明这件事更让我困扰。
It just bothers you. You don't want to be dead, but you don't want to be alive forever.
这困扰着你。你不想死，但你也不想永远活着。
Well, actually, if you're dead you probably don't know you're dead. But I just can't imagine the state of being dead. It's easy to understand. Something dies. It's dead. But if it's you, that's not so easy, because then there's nothing. It's just-- it's just--
嗯，实际上，如果你死了，你可能就不知道自己死了。但我只是无法想象死后的那种状态。理解它很容易：某物死了，它就死了。但如果是你，就没那么容易了，因为那时什么都没有。这只是……只是……
And it bothers you you can't imagine that. Or it bothers you that you--
让你困扰的是你无法想象那个状态？还是让你困扰的是……
I guess. I guess.
我想是吧，我想是吧。
Because you talk about this all the time.
因为你总是谈论这个。
Well, because I'm an old guy. I could die any minute now, right?
好吧，因为我是一个老头了。我随时都可能死，对吧？
OK.
好吧。
Right? I'm sort of at the average age that everybody around me is dying at. Did I put the "at" in twice?
对吧？我差不多到了周围所有人都在去世的平均年龄了。我刚才是不是把“去世”说了两次？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Melissa and I went back to her office. Honestly, I do think that's part of my sadness about the Fermi Paradox. I'm older now. My parents are getting older. I have kids. Questions that used to just seem philosophical, they feel very different now, much more real.
梅丽莎和我回到她的办公室。老实说，我认为这确实是我为费米悖论感到难过的一部分原因。我老了，父母在老去，我有孩子了。那些过去看起来只是哲学层面的问题，现在感觉非常不同，真实得多。
Haven't you felt sad? You've never felt-- yeah. You never felt physics-sad like that about something?
你从来没感到悲伤吗？你从来没……是的。你从来没因为某种事感到过“物理学上的悲伤”吗？
I'm kind of pissed off at the-- I get kind of sad at the speed of light.
我有点被……光速弄得火大。
Yeah?
是吗？
Like, why is it so small?
它为什么这么小？
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
No, really.
不，认真的。
I know. Most people think of the speed of light as pretty fast, but the galaxy's a big place. If we ever start text messaging with aliens, it's going to be a pretty big delay.
我知道。大多数人认为光速很快，但银河系太大了。如果我们开始和外星人发短信，延迟会非常大。
You know, four years to Alpha Centauri, right?
你知道，到比邻星要四年，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, it just sets a tone that's bad. It's just like a speed limit that you can't get over. Can we do something, though? What is the Drake Equation now?
我的意思是，这定下了一个很糟的基调。就像一个无法超越的限速。不过我们可以做点什么吗？现在的德雷克方程是怎么样的？
Melissa and I sat down and did what we probably should have done from the start. The Drake Equation is physicist's best attempt to calculate how many other civilizations are out there. It's quantitative, to the extent that you can be quantitative about this question. Basically what Fermi might have been doing on a napkin or whatever or at lunch all those years ago.
梅丽莎和我坐下来做了我们本该从一开始就做的事。德雷克方程是物理学家计算银河系中还有多少文明的最佳尝试。它是定量的，就关于这个问题的定量程度而言。基本上就是费米多年前在餐巾纸或午餐时可能做的计算。
Here, you want to read it to me?
来，你想读给我听吗？
n equals r star times f sub p. (INTERVIEWER) DAVID KESTENBAUM: Can I erase some stuff?
N等于R星乘以f的p次方。（采访者）大卫：我可以擦掉一些东西吗？
Yeah, yeah. You can erase anything.
可以，可以。你可以擦掉任何东西。
On the left side of the equation is n. That's the number you're trying to calculate. How many advanced civilizations are in the galaxy? To calculate n, there are a bunch of other numbers you have to put in and multiply together.
等式左边是N。这就是你要尝试计算的数字。银河系中有多少高级文明？要计算N，你得填入并乘上其他一堆数字。
You start with how often stars form in the galaxy, then what fraction of those stars have planets around them. We actually have data on this. Then you need the odds of life evolving-- which happened pretty quickly here on Earth after it cooled-- the odds of intelligent life developing, and finally, how long you think civilizations last. The result, how many advanced civilizations might there be in the galaxy? 156 million.
首先是银河系中恒星形成的频率，然后是多少比例的恒星周围有行星。我们确实有这方面的数据。然后你需要生命进化的几率——在地球冷却后生命很快就出现了——智慧生命发展的几率，最后是你认为文明能存续多久。结果是，银河系中可能存在多少高级文明？1.56亿。
In the galaxy?
在银河系里？
Yeah. Yeah, in the galaxy.
是的。是的，在银河系里。
That's crazy.
这太疯狂了。
It made me feel great that that might be true, but then Melissa kept reading. Oh, she says, there's a different answer you get if you tweak the numbers a bit, based on how likely you think it is for life to evolve, et cetera. In that case, the number of intelligent civilizations goes way down.
这让我觉得那个数字可能是真的，感觉棒极了，但随后梅丽莎继续往下读。她说，哦，如果你根据你认为生命进化的可能性等因素稍微调整一下数字，结果会完全不同。那样的话，智慧文明的数量会急剧下降。
As an example of a low estimate, combining NASA's star formation rates, the rare earth hypothesis, Mayor's view on intelligence, Drake's view of communication, and Shermer's estimate of lifetime, the number of civilizations could be as low as 9.1 times 10 to the minus 11th.
作为一个低估算的例子，结合美国宇航局的恒星形成率、稀有地球假说、梅耶关于智慧的观点、德雷克的交流观点和舍默关于寿命的估算，文明的数量可能低至9.1乘以10的负11次方。
Oh. What? What's the number?
哦。什么？那是什么数字？
9 times 10 to the minus 11th. In other words, 0.0000. Basically, zero.
9乘以10的负11次方。换句话说，0.000……基本上是零。
Zero, i.e., suggesting that we are probably alone in this galaxy, and possibly the observable universe.
零。也就是说，这表明我们在银河系中很可能是孤独的，甚至可能在整个可观测宇宙中也是。
The physicist term for this is that the problem is poorly constrained. Meaning, basically, we have no idea. There could be 156 million alien civilizations out there, or zero, or somewhere in between. So the whole thing is kind of a Rorschach test. I was worried about the possibility that n might be 0. Melissa?
物理学界把这称为问题缺乏约束。意思是，基本上一无所知。银河系外可能有1.56亿个外星文明，也可能是零，或者介于两者之间。所以整件事就像个罗夏墨迹测验。我担心的是N可能是0的可能性。梅丽莎呢？
What I'm worried about is it's 156 million, in which case, we're probably screwed very soon, like any day now. Boom, aliens are going to come. 156 million in our galaxy?
我担心的是N是1.56亿，那样的话，我们很可能很快就完了，就像随时都会发生。轰，外星人要来了。银河系里有1.56亿个文明？
I love that you're afraid of the other end.
我喜欢你害怕另一个极端的这种想法。
Yeah, I am afraid of the other end. You should be, too.
是的，我也怕另一端。你也应该怕。
So I should celebrate the silence, the great silence?
所以我应该庆祝这种沉默，这种大沉默？
Well, I think, you know, we're in a good place now.
嗯，我觉得，你知道，我们现在处于一个不错的位置。
I hadn't thought about it that way until this very moment, but it's true. We haven't encountered some terrifying alien race. And we haven't somehow proven we're alone. We don't know.
直到这一刻我才想到这一点，但这是真的。我们还没有遇到什么可怕的外星种族。我们也还没有证明我们是孤独的。我们不知道。
That's right. Yeah, we're in the sweet spot. We're not dead, and there's still hope.
没错。是的，我们正处于甜蜜点。我们没灭亡，而且还有希望。
Right.
对。
Yeah.
是的。
OK, I feel good about that.
好吧，这感觉不错。
OK, good. I'm glad.
好的，很好。我很高兴。
I realize that is the least physicsy resolution you can come to, that we should feel good not knowing the answer to some big question. But I do feel better. I think I turned the corner when we talked to Paul, because Paul agreed that Fermi had posed a serious problem.
我意识到这是对一个大问题所能得出的最不“物理学”的结论了，那就是我们应该为不知道答案而感到高兴。但我确实感觉好多了。我想当和保罗交谈时，我就想通了，因为保罗也同意费米确实提出了一个严肃的问题。
But he'd looked it in the face and he came out on the other side, still believing intelligent life is out there and looking for it. He probably won't hear anything, but I think I'm OK with that. Maybe it is better than no.
但他正视了它，并从中走了出来，仍然相信外面有智慧生命并寻找着它们。他可能什么都听不到，但我想我能接受。也许这确实比“没有”要好。
David Kestenbaum.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
[STATIC]
[静电声]
What is this sound?
这是什么声音？
Yeah, so nature produces a lot of radio signals. And it's the vibrations of molecules and atoms that are in dust clouds, and in stars, and in galaxies.
嗯，自然界会产生很多无线电信号。这是尘埃云、恒星和星系中分子和原子的振动。
Dan Werthimer. He's the chief scientist at the SETI research center in Berkeley. SETI is the Search for Extraterrestrial Intelligence. He sent us this sound of data from one of the world's biggest radio telescopes, the Arecibo telescope in Puerto Rico, which points at stars, listening for signals sent by other intelligent life.
丹·沃西默。他是伯克利地外文明搜寻中心（SETI）的首席科学家。SETI就是寻找地外智慧生命。他给我们发送了来自世界最大射电望远镜之一——波多黎各阿雷西博望远镜的数据声音，它指向恒星，监听来自其他智慧生命的信号。
What we're listening for is an eee or ooo. We don't know what frequency. Or maybe a bip-bip-bip-bip. It might be buried. It might be a very weak kind of eee, but it'd be buried in the static that you hear when you point your telescope to the stars.
我们在监听的是一种“咿”或“呜”的声音。我们不知道频率。或者可能是“哔-哔-哔-哔”。它可能被掩盖了。可能是一种非常微弱的“咿”声，但会被你把望远镜指向星空时听到的静电噪声淹没。
We've only just begun looking for other life. And of all the radio frequencies we can search, we've looked at fewer than 1%. In 40 years, Dan says, we have found nothing promising yet.
我们才刚刚开始搜寻其他生命。在我们能搜寻的所有无线电频率中，我们查看的不到1%。丹说，40年来，我们还没发现任何有希望的信号。
Coming up, searching for intelligent life in your own marriage. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，在你的婚姻中搜寻智慧生命。从芝加哥公共广播电台收听我们的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Fermi's Paradox. We have stories of people heading out on their own on very personal quest to figure out are we alone? We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, "Two Can Be as Sad as One."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“费米悖论”。我们有关于人们踏上个人探索之旅去寻找“我们是否孤独”的故事。现在进入节目的第二幕，“双倍的悲伤，双倍的孤独”。
We're in this show about loneliness. We now turn to one of the loneliest experiences a person can possibly have, and that's marriage. I think the thing that I was least prepared for in marriage is how lonely it can be, when things go badly, I mean. And there's this recording of this couple trying to get past all the stuff that's dividing them that I think illustrates really well how hard that can be and what it really means to do it.
这一集讲的是孤独。现在我们转向一种人可能经历的最孤独的体验，那就是婚姻。我想在婚姻中我最没准备好的就是当事情变糟时，那是多么孤独。录音里有一对夫妇试图跨越他们之间分歧的一切，我觉得这很好地说明了这有多难，以及真正做到这一点意味着什么。
This recording is from this new podcast in which a real-life therapist records her real-life sessions with real couples who've agreed to be recorded. The therapist is Esther Perel, who's also the author of the books Mating in Captivity and the upcoming, The State of Affairs.
这段录音来自一档新播客，一位现实生活中的治疗师记录了她与同意被录音的真实夫妇的谈话。这位治疗师是埃丝特·佩瑞尔，也是《囚禁中的配偶》和即将出版的《婚外情》一书的作者。
I've listened to a few episodes of her podcast now, and OK, my mom was a marriage therapist. She wrote a book about her techniques and research. She did trainings for other therapists. I've been in couples counseling myself with my wife. So I know about this world, and I found listening to Perel to be completely fascinating.
我已经听了几期她的播客，好吧，我妈妈是婚姻治疗师。她写过关于她技术和研究的书，还为其他治疗师做培训。我自己也和妻子一起做过夫妻咨询。所以我了解这个世界，我发现听佩瑞尔的节目非常迷人。
She's a very active therapist. I think that's the best way to say it. She talks a ton, takes what the couple says to her and then says it back to them in this way where it's like she's a LeBron-level basketball player, passing the ball to them, and then urging them down the court, running alongside, and shouting encouragement and instructions and very occasional razzing along the way. She's such an intense listener that it makes interviewing her a very odd experience. I tried to explain this to her after she and I had been sitting in the studio together for over an hour.
她是一位非常主动的治疗师。我觉得这样说最合适。她话很多，将这对夫妇对她说的话拿过来，然后用一种方式回应他们，就像她是勒布朗级的篮球运动员，把球传给他们，然后催促他们冲向篮下，跟在旁边跑，大喊鼓励和指令，偶尔还会带点嘲讽。她是一位如此专注的听众，以至于采访她成了极其奇特的经历。在她和我坐在录音室里超过一个小时后，我试着向她解释这一点。
I rarely am interviewing somebody-- I'm not sure if I've ever interviewed somebody who's watching me as much as I'm watching them.
我很少采访别人……我不确定我是否采访过像我观察他们一样观察我的人。
Yes, especially when your throat chokes.
是的，尤其是当你的喉咙哽住的时候。
When my throat chokes? What does that mean?
当我的喉咙哽住？那是什么意思？
When I spoke and you would get--
当我说话而你变得……
And what does that mean when I do that?
当我那样做时，那是什么意思？
When the little polyvagal nerve quivers, it means that I'm saying something that's reaching you.
当迷走神经颤动时，那意味着我说的东西触动了你。
She's talking about the vagus nerve, which runs down your neck and into your body. Apparently, very revealing. The therapy session that I found so interesting, and all the sessions in her podcast, are a kind of session that Perel does a lot of.
她在谈论迷走神经，它沿着你的脖子延伸到身体内部。显然，这非常有揭示性。我觉得很有趣的那次治疗，以及她播客里的所有治疗，都是佩瑞尔经常做的一种咨询。
She does these consultations where instead of people coming in week after week, like normal therapy, a couple will come in just one time, for two or three hours. And then that's it. No more therapy. People fly in from all over for this. Perel only takes couples whose problems she thinks she can make a dent in in so little time.
她做这些咨询时，不是让人们像普通治疗那样每周来一次，而是一对夫妇只来一次，花两三个小时。然后就结束了。没有后续治疗。人们从各地飞来参加。佩瑞尔只接受她认为在这么短时间内能有所作为的夫妻。
And what can you accomplish in a two or three-hour session, where you see the people once?
在一次两三小时的咨询中，你只见到他们一次，能完成什么？
So much. The story that the people come in with is not the story they leave with. That's the first goal.
完成很多。人们带着进来的故事，并不是他们离开时的故事。那是第一个目标。
Yeah.
是的。
The second thing is to see if they can actually experience with each other, even a glimpse of it, that which they may be longing for. Can they have a different kind of connection, a different kind of experience of themselves and with each other in the room?
第二件事是看看他们是否能真正与对方产生某种体验，哪怕只是一瞥，那正是他们可能所渴望的。他们能在房间里获得一种不同类型的连接，一种对自己和对方不同的体验吗？
And with most of the couples, can you get them to that point? That seems very advanced.
对于大多数夫妇，你能让他们达到那种程度吗？这看起来非常高级。
Not necessarily. I mean, with many.
不一定。我是说，对许多人来说可以。
It can make for suspenseful listening, hearing her try to get couples to that point. This particular couple came into her office on a Wednesday morning this fall and sat on the couch together. They'd been married for nearly 40 years, middle class people. They met when the woman was just 15. They have children and grandchildren.
听她试着让夫妇达到那一点，可能会非常扣人心弦。这对特定的夫妇在今年秋天的一个周三早上来到她的办公室，并排坐在沙发上。他们结婚快40年了，中产阶级。他们相识时妻子才15岁。他们有孩子和孙辈。
And then, three years ago, the wife discovered that her husband had been cheating on her. Not just like with one person for a few months or a few years, but widely and compulsively for most of their marriage. I mean, for decades. These were one-night stands and paying for sex, he said.
然后，三年前，妻子发现丈夫一直在欺骗她。不仅仅是几个月或几年和某一个人，而是大范围地、强迫性地持续了他们婚姻的大部分时间。我是说，几十年。他说，那些都是一夜情和花钱买性服务。
They both said they'd been happy together all those years in the marriage with a good sex life, and she wanted to stay together if it was at all possible because she wanted to keep what they'd had that was good. But you know, being lied to for decades, it's like it robbed her of her past. She couldn't tell what was real, what to trust. She told Perel in the session.
他们都说这些年来他们的婚姻一直很幸福，性生活也很和谐，她想尽可能维持婚姻，因为她想保留他们过去拥有的美好。但你知道，被谎言蒙蔽了几十年，这简直是抢走了她的过去。她无法分辨什么是真的，什么值得信任。她在咨询中告诉佩瑞尔。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
So yeah, I mean, we had a good marriage and that's why I'm still here. I mean, he was a good husband. He was the best father ever, always there with our children, always loving to me.
是的，我是说，我们的婚姻很美好，这就是我留在这里的原因。我是说，他是个好丈夫。他是最好的父亲，总是陪伴着我们的孩子，总是爱我。
And I don't doubt for one second that he didn't love me with all of his heart. I never knew anything was wrong. And I don't want to say I'm one of those women who lived in a tunnel without any peripheral vision.
我一点也不怀疑他曾全心全意地爱我。我从未知道有任何不对劲。我不想说我是那种生活在隧道里完全没有周边视野的女人。
If something came up, I'd question him, and he'd tell me the story and I'd believe him. Why not believe him? He's never done anything to cause me to mistrust him. Now I look at him, and if he tells me this pen is red, I will turn it 15 different ways today. And that's a huge issue for us now.
如果有事发生，我会问他，他会编个故事，我就相信他。为什么不相信他？他从未做过任何让我不信任他的事。现在我看着他，如果他告诉我这支笔是红色的，今天我会把它转15个不同的角度去检查。这对我们来说现在是个巨大的问题。
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
They spend a little bit of time in the session, not a lot, really, on what might have led him into this double life. He grew up in a violent home, saw his mother regularly beaten by his dad, was beaten himself, and witnessed way more than he could absorb or handle as a kid.
他们在咨询中花了一些时间——其实不多——讨论是什么导致他陷入这种双重生活。他在一个暴力的家庭中长大，经常目睹母亲被父亲殴打，自己也挨打，小时候所见所闻远超他所能吸收或承受的程度。
Perel tells him there are lots of boys who go through that, and then grow up, split their personalities in half, like he'd done, treat women one way when they were away from home, and then be super responsible with their families when they are home. He seems kind of wrecked in the recording. It's only now that he was finally facing the truth about what he'd done and who he'd been.
佩瑞尔告诉他，有很多男孩经历过那样的事，长大后将性格一分为二，就像他所做的那样：离家时对待女性是一种态度，而回家时又对家庭超级负责。他在录音里看起来几乎崩溃了。直到现在，他才终于面对关于他做了什么以及他是谁的真相。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
I've wasted 59 years living a mask, living a dual life. My kids didn't really know me. I was this other person. As much as I was involved with them, I wasn't present in my life. And I can't get that back. I wasted my life.
我浪费了59年活在面具下，过着双重生活。我的孩子并不真正认识我。我曾经是另一个人。尽管我参与了他们的生活，但我并没有真正出现在我的生活中。我找不回那些时间了。我浪费了我的生命。
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
He insisted he wasn't cheating because he was unhappy in his marriage. He said he was happy. He said he didn't love any of these women.
他坚称他欺骗不是因为婚姻不幸福。他说他很幸福。他说他不爱那些女性中的任何一个。
And his wife was trying to believe him, that this was a compulsion that had nothing to do with her. But she was also struggling with the fact that her friends and relatives could not understand why she was staying with him after everything he'd done. They judged her, even her own daughter.
而他的妻子正在努力相信他，相信这是一种与她无关的强迫症。但她也正在挣扎于这样一个事实：她的朋友和亲戚无法理解为什么在发生这一切后她还留在他身边。他们评判她，连她自己的女儿也是。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
And is she mad at you?
她对你生气吗？
Yeah, she was very mad at me.
是的，她对我非常生气。
For not throwing him out?
因为你没把他赶走？
Well, I did throw him out, but for not ending it. Yeah, they thought I was weak. They thought I had Stockholm Syndrome. They felt I-- you know, because we've been together so long, they just felt that I was too weak in character. And they didn't like what they saw.
好吧，我确实把他赶走了，但因为没彻底断绝。是的，他们认为我很软弱。他们认为我患了斯德哥尔摩综合征。他们觉得我……你知道，因为我们在一起太久了，他们只是觉得我性格太软弱。他们不喜欢他们所看到的。
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
Perel told me that it was seeing the wife's isolation that made her realize what it was that she wanted to accomplish in this session.
佩瑞尔告诉我，正是看到妻子的孤立，让她意识到她在这次咨询中想要完成的目标。
She's decided to stay, and she needs a dignified way, a way with self-respect, to feel that her choice is valid. But in order for it to be valid, she needs something from him that I sense she has yet to receive, that he is struggling to give her. And it's that button that I choose to focus on during the session.
她决定留下，她需要一种尊严的方式、一种保持自尊的方式来感到她的选择是有效的。但要使之有效，她需要从他那里得到某种我感觉到她尚未得到、而他正挣扎着给出的东西。我选择在咨询过程中关注那个按钮。
And what is the thing that she needs from him?
她需要从他那里得到的东西是什么？
She needs a degree of accountability and recognition about the pain that he caused her. But now he's so busy with his own pain that he has a hard time owning the hurt that he caused her. So he feels so bad about himself, that he can't feel bad for her.
她需要某种责任感和对他给她造成痛苦的认可。但现在他太忙于自己的痛苦，以至于他很难承担起对她造成的伤害。所以他对自己感觉太糟糕，以至于无法对她感到难过。
So a lot of the session is Perel trying to get the husband to understand and acknowledge his wife's pain, and I'm going to play a stretch of this now that's several minutes long from the therapy session, starting from when Perel first brings this up. And what you hear is this very human thing I think all of us in relationships have done. He's not able to take in what they're saying to him at first. And it slowly, slowly gets through.
所以咨询中很大一部分是佩瑞尔试图让丈夫理解并承认妻子的痛苦。现在我打算播放一段从这次治疗中截取的几分钟长的片段，从佩瑞尔第一次提出这一点开始。你们听到的是一种我认为我们所有人在关系中都做过的非常人性化的事。他起初无法领会他们对他所说的话。然后，慢慢地，慢慢地，他领悟了。
Warning, if you're listening to the internet version of our show, we have unbeeped the curse words in this version. You can get a beeped version at our website.
警告，如果你听的是我们节目的互联网版本，我们已经取消了对咒骂词汇的消音。你可以在我们的网站上获取消音版本。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
How much-- how much does he talk about what he did to you versus what happened to him?
对于你对她所做的事，和你自己身上发生的事，你谈论了多少？
I would say he talks more about what happened to him--
我会说他谈论发生在自己身上的事更多……
Correct.
正确。
--than what happened to me.
……比发生在我身上的多。
I'm sensing that. That is off balance.
我感觉到了。那是失衡的。
OK.
好吧。
So listen to her very carefully because I think she may have tried to say this already more than once.
所以非常仔细地听她说，因为我觉得她可能已经不止一次试图说出这一点了。
I really feel that you talk more about you and the pain you're going through than the horrific pain you caused me. All of your pain was self-inflicted. You made choices. You made decisions. You put yourself out there.
我真的觉得你谈论你自己和你正在经历的痛苦，远多于你给我造成的恐怖痛苦。你所有的痛苦都是自找的。是你做出了选择。是你做出了决定。是你让自己陷入其中。
But everything that was done to me is not something I asked for and not something I wanted to be party to. I mean, I know you know you hurt me, but I don't think you really get the magnitude. Because it always switches back to you.
但对我所做的一切，不是我要求的，也不是我想参与的。我是说，我知道你知道你伤害了我，但我认为你并没有真正领会其严重性。因为它总是会回到你自己身上。
But the point of the whole story is--
但整个故事的重点是……
Before you but, can you just tell her what you just heard so that we can know that it reached you?
在你“但是”之前，你能复述一下你刚才听到的吗？这样我们才知道它传达到了你这里。
That I'm not compassionate to your trauma and I talk more about my own trauma than your trauma. Does that pretty well sum it up? Talking about it just brings us both to such a bad place and all it does is bring out anger and hate from you every time I try to talk about this with you.
我对你的创伤缺乏同情心，我谈论自己的创伤多于谈论你的创伤。这总结得够准确吗？谈论它只会让我们俩都陷入极其糟糕的状态，每次我试图和你谈论这个，它只会引出你的愤怒和仇恨。
So let me try to help you do this in a way that is more healing and less activating. Because you're in a certain phase. You've gone from the 59 years of trying to deny everything, numb myself, feel nothing, medicate, and now I'm in touch.
让我试着帮你用一种更治愈、更少刺激性的方式做到这一点。因为你处于某个阶段。你经历了59年试图否认一切、麻木自己、感觉不到任何东西、药物治疗的阶段，而现在我有所接触了。
I'm in touch with myself. I'm figuring it out. I'm putting the pieces together and it's making sense for the first time. There is no mask in front of me and I am so deep into myself. I'm so fricking self-absorbed!
我接触到了自己。我正在弄清楚这一切。我正在拼凑碎片，它第一次说得通了。我面前没有面具，我深深地沉浸在自己里面。我太TM自我中心了！
It's still more about me. It was about me then, and it is about me now. And now you gotta step out of yourself for a moment.
这仍然更多是关于我。那时是关于我，现在还是关于我。现在你必须暂时跳出自己。
If you attend to her primary concern, then she can attend to your primary trajectory. But she can only do that if there is space inside of her. And that space is created because you are saying to her, how are you doing? from a place of responsibility, not from a place of shame.
如果你照顾她的核心关切，那么她就可以照顾你的核心轨迹。但只有当她内心有空间时，她才能做到这一点。那个空间是因为你在说“你好吗？”——从一种责任感出发，而不是从一种羞耻感出发。
I take responsibility.
我承担责任。
Yeah.
是的。
Be very clear. I take 100%. There is no excuse. There were a couple of reasons.
说清楚。我承担100%。没有任何借口。虽然有几个原因。
But the problem is that if you go to her and you say to her, I can't believe how I treated you, you have to be able to not say, I feel so bad about me for having done this. It's the difference between, I feel so bad about myself, versus I feel bad for you.
但问题是，如果你走向她说，“我不相信我竟然这样对待你”，你必须能够不去说，“我对自己做了这种事感到太糟糕了”。这区别于“我对自己感觉太糟糕”，和“我为你感到难过”。
That makes a lot of sense.
这很有道理。
And what she needs is for you to finally step out of yourself and actually be able to say, I feel so bad for you.
她需要的是你终于跳出自己，真正能说出“我为你感到难过”。
I didn't do it to you. I didn't cause you all of this pain in your life, but you caused me all this pain in my life. You have to find a way to help me through it.
我没对你做这些。我没让你一生中遭受所有这些痛苦，但你让我的生命中遭受了所有这些痛苦。你必须找到一种方法引导我走出这一切。
I came to you last night. I hug you and you--
我昨晚去找你。我抱你，然后你……
And you have to let me say that.
你必须让我说出来。
But people, you're going to help each other, help each other. You're going to learn that together.
但各位，你们要互相帮助，互相帮助。你们会一起学到这一点。
So when you get all upset that he has to, he has to, he doesn't know. He doesn't disagree, but he doesn't know. So you tell him what you want. Don't tell him what he has to or what he does wrong.
所以当你因为他必须、他必须这样做而感到沮丧时，他不知道。他并不反对，但他不知道。所以你告诉他你想要什么。不要告诉他他必须做什么，或者他做错了什么。
I ask her that all the time. Tell me what you want, I'm there. I am all in. I am 100% all in.
我总是问她。告诉我你想要什么，我会配合。我全心全意投入。我100%全心投入。
I believe you.
我相信你。
I am self-absorbed. I got to get out of that. It's putting her before my own self needs. And it's important for me--
我是自我中心的。我得走出来。这要把她的需求放在我自己的需求之前。这对我很重要……
It's beautiful. It's beautiful. But your wife is more isolated than you.
很美。很美。但你的妻子比你更孤立。
OK.
好的。
And she needs not an apology. She needs an acknowledgement of her experience.
她不需要道歉。她需要的是对她经历的认可。
Yep.
是的。
It's just that. You can use the words you want. You can use your body. Let it out.
就这么简单。你可以用你想要的词汇。你可以用你的身体语言。让它释放出来。
I love you.
我爱你。
I know.
我知道。
I can't imagine what you're going through--
我无法想象你正在经历什么……
[WOMAN SOBS]
[女子啜泣]
--but I'm here for you.
……但我在这里陪着你。
That was good. Do you understand the difference?
那很好。你明白区别了吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我明白。
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
So at that point, it seems like he's got it.
在那一点上，看起来他领悟到了。
You know, nobody ever apologized to him. He has no experience of someone saying, I'm so sorry I hurt you. So it's not something that he knows to do and that he just sobbed. And then for her, too.
你知道，从来没人向他道歉过。他没有过听到某人说“我很抱歉伤害了你”的经验。所以这不是他知道该做的事，他刚才啜泣了。这对她来说也是一样。
Because until now, see, when she would ask for this, she would also do it with so much venom and so much anger that it was very difficult for him to come close. It's like she would say, feel for me, but with such aggression sometimes. Sometimes, not--
因为直到现在，你看，当她请求这个时，她也会带着太多的恶毒和愤怒，以至于他很难靠近。就像她会说，对他人的同情，但有时带着太大的攻击性。有时，不是……
And to be fair, understandable. She's so hurt and she's so upset.
公平地说，这可以理解。她受伤太深，太难过了。
Of course.
当然。
Yeah.
是的。
It's a given. It's a given that she must have rage inside of her. But it's also a given that when she approaches him with that kind of rage, she won't get the kind of care and compassion that she wants.
这不言而喻。她内心肯定充满愤怒。但同样不言而喻的是，当她带着那种愤怒接近他时，她是得不到她想要的关怀和同情的。
So how do I soften her so that he can soften? Because if she goes at him, then he will stay stiff. And if he stays stiff, then she will remain more angry and then you are in the same loop.
所以我该如何软化她，从而让他也能软化？因为如果她去攻击他，他就会保持僵硬。如果他保持僵硬，她就会继续愤怒，然后你们就陷入了同样的循环。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
So I give words to what I know she's asking, but because I'm not experienced-- I don't have her history, I can do it without the edge. And when I can do it without the edge, then he can come forward.
所以我把我所知道她要求的用言语表达出来，但因为我没经历过……我没有她的历史，我可以不带棱角地说出来。当我能不带棱角地说出来时，他就能走出来。
And then they can have this new experience with each other, which they haven't been having.
然后他们就能互相产生这种新的体验，这是他们之前没有过的。
That's the enactment that I'm talking about. I think she actually holds him at that moment.
那就是我所说的制定。我想那一刻她确实拥抱了他。
So you go through this with the two of them and they have this moment. And he truly seems to understand. And then the next thing that happens is the wife starts talking about her experience.
所以你和他们一起经历了这一切，他们有了那一刻。他看起来确实理解了。然后接下来发生的是妻子开始谈论她的经历。
And she says, the reason why she's able to continue staying with him is that she believes that the sex was casual, and that he didn't love anyone else. And then she talks about how she still questions, well, did he love her if he could do all that?
她说，她之所以能继续留在他身边的原因，是她相信那些性关系都是随意的，他并没有爱上别人。然后她谈到她仍然在怀疑，好吧，如果他能做所有这些，他爱她吗？
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
I question how could you have really loved me if you did that to me? You know?
我质疑，如果你那样对我，你怎么可能真的爱我？你知道吗？
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
And then she says this.
然后她说了这个。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
You know, when we calculate in my head exactly how many years it was, 22 years. 22 years.
你知道，当我在脑海中准确算出是多少年时，22年。22年。
We were married 36. You take away the two. You take away the 12. You cheated on me for 22 years. It's mind-boggling.
我们结婚36年了。除去那两年，除去那12年。你欺骗了我22年。这简直不可思议。
I didn't cheat on her for 12 years.
我没欺骗她12年。
It's just mind-boggling.
这简直不可思议。
Mister, your wife has just said so many important things, and the only thing you respond to is the calculus?
先生，你妻子刚刚说了这么多重要的事情，而你唯一回应的就是那个算术？
We go through this all the time. It's the calculus.
我们总是经历这个。就是那个算术。
You have to respond differently than what you just did.
你必须做出与刚才不同的回应。
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
It's like he's lost the lesson, and he's talking about himself. He's defending himself. He's not talking about what she's feeling.
看起来他忘了那个教训，他又在谈论自己了。他在为自己辩护。他没有谈论她的感受。
Well, I'm going to show it to him again. This has to be repeated. But I actually have a different experience of him. She just said 22 years, and he receives this like, what a piece of shit I am. And it's so unbearable.
嗯，我会再给他演示一遍。这必须重复。但我对他其实有不同的看法。她刚才说22年，他接受的信息是“我真是一个烂人”。这实在太难忍受了。
And so then he brings out the 12 years to say, I'm not that bad. That's the calculus. So now I'm going to help him stay with her.
所以他才搬出那12年来辩解，想说“我没那么坏”。这就是那个算术。所以现在我要帮他回到她身边。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
You know you have to respond differently than what you just did. You can do better.
你知道你必须做出与刚才不同的回应。你能做得更好。
Yeah. Yeah. It was a horrible-- it's a horrible thing that you had to go through there. You're my family, and as crazy as it sounds, how can I do this to my family?
是的。是的。这是一件可怕的……你必须经历这些真是太可怕了。你是我的家人，听起来很疯狂，我怎么能对我的家人做这种事？
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
And then he stumbles again. He tries to reassure his wife that there is no way he's ever going to cheat on her again. And then he starts talking about the lessons that he has learned and how certain it is that he's changed. In other words, he's talking about himself. And Perel steps in again.
然后他又绊倒了。他试图向妻子保证他绝不会再欺骗她。然后他开始谈论他学到的教训以及他改变得有多彻底。换句话说，他在谈论自己。佩瑞尔再次介入。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
And I'm trying to tell you--
我正试图告诉你……
You know what may be more helpful? Don't try to convince her.
你知道什么可能更有帮助吗？不要试图说服她。
OK.
好的。
Because you can't be that certain either. And most of the time, talk less and touch more. Talk less. You overtalk. So when she gets upset, half the time, all you need to do is hold her and just say I'm here. And for the rest, if you allow me, shut the fuck up.
因为你也没法那么确定。大多数时候，少说话，多触碰。少说话。你说得太多了。所以当她难过时，有一半时间，你所要做的只是拥抱她，说“我在这里”。其余的话，如果你允许我直说的话，闭上你该死的嘴。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Good advice.
好建议。
[END PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
It's interesting. There this idea that when you talk through your problems with your partner, it will alleviate loneliness. But here they are, talking, and it's just doing the opposite.
很有趣。这里有一个观点，当你和伴侣讨论问题时，它会缓解孤独感。但他们在这里讨论，却适得其反。
Yes, you can build walls with words and insurmountable barriers.
是的，你可以用言语筑起围墙和不可逾越的障碍。
Hearing your podcast, it seems so hard for people to come together. I was wondering if, in your line of work, if it makes you feel hopeful for most couples, and hopeful for the idea of people finding what they want with their partners?
听你的播客，人们走到一起似乎很难。我想知道，在你的工作中，这让你对大多数夫妇感到充满希望吗？对人们与伴侣找到他们想要的东西充满希望吗？
You know, the thing that just popped in my head is I have days where I have faith in humanity and days when I don't. I'll answer you from a different angle. I once wanted to write an article on couples that inspire. And I asked about 60, 70 people, at the time, if they knew of couples that inspired them. And the vast majority could sometimes come up with one.
你知道，我脑子里闪过的想法是，我有对人类充满信心的日子，也有不抱信心的日子。我换个角度回答你。我曾经想写一篇关于鼓舞人心的夫妇的文章。当时我问了大约60、70个人，看他们是否知道激励他们的夫妇。绝大多数人有时能想到一对。
Wow.
哇。
I never wrote the piece, but it's the answer to your question, right? It's that we can see some couples who are very good at this and some couples who are very good at that, but we don't have that many models where we just say, wow, this is who I want to be, how I want to be.
我从未写那篇文章，但这正是你问题的答案，对吧？我们可以看到一些夫妇很擅长这一点，一些很擅长那一点，但我们并没有多少可以让我们直接说“哇，这就是我想成为的人，这就是我想成为的样子”的模范。
Esther Perel, her new podcast, the Audible original series, Where Should We Begin with Esther Perel, can be found at audible.com/esther.
埃丝特·佩瑞尔，她的新播客，Audible原创系列《从哪里开始：埃丝特·佩瑞尔》，可在audible.com/esther收听。
Act 3, "Rosie's Paradox." So we end our show today with the story of one more person asking some very big questions. Stephanie Foo explains.
第三幕，“罗西的悖论”。节目最后我们讲述另一个人问出一些重大问题的故事。斯蒂芬妮·福为你解读。
About three years ago, my friend Matt's older daughter went through one of those hardcore phases where she got really into asking her dad a lot of questions. She was nine.
大约三年前，我朋友马特的大女儿经历了一个非常硬核的阶段，当时她非常喜欢问她爸爸很多问题。她九岁。
There's the why phase. And then the why phase can turn into the why not and explain and that endless string of questions. Like, why can't I have my own room? How do I get to school? Why can't we have a yard? Can I have a cookie? They're unrelenting.
会有“为什么”阶段。然后“为什么”阶段会变成“为什么不”、“解释一下”以及那无穷无尽的问题链。比如，为什么我不能有自己的房间？我怎么去学校？为什么我们没有院子？我能吃块饼干吗？这些都是没完没了的。
So one night, Matt was working from home and Rosie was bugging him with her questions.
所以一天晚上，马特在家办公，罗西一直在用问题缠着他。
And it was just one after the other after the other. And I was like, look, you've got to get just give me a minute. I'm working right now. Just go off and write them all down. Make me a list of the questions that you want me to answer, and I'll answer them for you.
简直是一个接一个。我说，听着，你得给我一分钟。我现在在工作。去把它们都写下来。列个清单，把你想让我回答的问题写给我，我会为你回答。
I thought it was going to be like three or four questions and then a picture of a rabbit or something. And I get this list and I look at it. And these are the essential, unanswerable questions of life.
我以为那会是三四个问题，然后画只兔子什么的。结果我拿到了那个清单，看了一下。这些是生命中本质的、无法回答的问题。
Read a few of these questions for me. Start at the very top.
给我读几个问题。从最上面开始。
OK, so, what is life? Why?
好的，那么，生命是什么？为什么？
That's the first question.
那是第一个问题。
It's the first question. It's the first thing she wants to know. Where do we go when we die? heaven? Explain. Another planet? Is heaven another planet?
是第一个问题。这是她想知道的第一件事。死后我们去哪儿？天堂？解释一下。另一个星球？天堂是另一个星球吗？
Why is there heaven or hell? Time? Why? Explain. Do we make worlds? Do we become like God? Why?
为什么有天堂或地狱？时间？为什么？解释一下。我们能创造世界吗？我们能变得像上帝一样吗？为什么？
Why do you do what you do? How do you know what's true? Who do you miss? Why? Explain. Do you miss anyone more than them, and does that change and how? And if that changes, was it worth missing them in the first place?
你为什么做你现在做的事？你怎么知道什么是真的？你想念谁？为什么？解释一下。你是否比想念别人更想念他们，这会改变吗？如果改变了，当初想念他们值得吗？
And my favorite is-- and this is pretty much just my jaw dropped, why any of this? I mean, my first reaction to them is-- I mean, I'm proud of her. And then I realize I actually have to answer these questions, right?
我最喜欢的是——这简直让我惊掉下巴——为什么会有这一切？我是说，我对它们的第一反应是……我很为她骄傲。然后我意识到我真的必须回答这些问题，对吧？
They're are about three pages, single-spaced, of handwritten questions, about 50 questions total. But a promise was a promise, so Matt got to work. He's a professor at West Point, teaches writing. And so he took a professorial approach to it and started researching answers for her, looking up quotes on each topic, spending weeks, sometimes months, writing each answer.
大概有三页手写的问题，单倍行距，总共约50个问题。但承诺就是承诺，所以马特开始工作了。他在西点军校当教授，教写作。所以他以教授的方式处理这些问题，开始为她研究答案，查找每个主题的引语，花了数周，有时数月，写出每个答案。
What's the shortest and what's the longest you've ever spent? And what's the hardest one?
你花时间最短和最长的是哪个？最难的是哪个？
So I think the longest one is one that I haven't finished answering for her yet, which is, what is love?
我觉得最长的一个是我还没写完回答的，那就是：什么是爱？
What's been the easiest one to answer so far?
到目前为止最容易回答的是哪个？
Is heaven another planet? No.
天堂是另一个星球吗？不。
I got him to read me one of the answers he worked hardest on, the answer to, "Time. Why? Explain."
我让他给我读了他写得最辛苦的一个答案，回答的是：“时间。为什么？解释一下。”
Could you read it for me?
你能读给我听吗？
Sure. "So tell me what and tell me why, and the burden is on me to justify this to you. Perhaps that's what time means in the end is a justification or a lack of being justified. And I don't really know what "justification" means. There was an old movie I saw when I was a kid in your grandmother's house with the--"
当然。“告诉我什么和为什么，重担就在我身上，必须向你证明这一点。也许这就是时间的最终含义：一种证明，或缺乏证明。我并不真正理解“证明”意味着什么。我小时候在你祖母家看过一部老电影……”
He quotes Camus, then brings in the Millennium Falcon, then Saint Augustine, then Kierkegaard. Rosie was nine. All his answers are like this.
他引用了加缪，然后带入了千年隼号，然后是圣奥古斯丁，然后是克尔凯郭尔。罗西当时九岁。他所有的答案都像这样。
"Kierkegaard gets to this point after either/oring everything. He says, why did I not die as a baby?"
“克尔凯郭尔在一切都非此即彼之后达到了这个点。他问，为什么我没有作为婴儿死去？”
I'm a grown-up and I find it impossible to follow your answers. Honestly, I have not any idea what you're saying.
我是个成年人，我都觉得你的答案完全无法理解。老实说，我根本不知道你在说什么。
Yeah. I mean, I really don't understand half of what I just said either, right? To be honest.
是的。说实话，我刚才说的一半我也没理解。
What his answers do have going for them is sincerity. The time one ends like this.
他答案的优点在于诚意。关于时间的那篇结尾是这样的。
"And one of my favorite stories by a guy named William Faulkner. There was a daddy who gives his kid a watch and says, "I give you this watch, not that you might remember time, but so that you might forget it for a little while." I can only tell you that time is me turning and turning while the world is turning around a star that turns around a center that turns around the whole time. Among all the other things and the little turning animals and all the little turning worlds, there's me trying to turn to you."
“威廉·福克纳写过我最喜欢的一个故事。有个爸爸给孩子一块手表，说：‘我给你这块表，不是为了让你记得时间，而是为了让你能忘记它一会儿。’我只能告诉你，时间就是我旋转着，而世界围绕着一颗星星旋转，星星围绕着一个中心旋转，旋转个不停。在所有其他事物、所有旋转的小动物和所有旋转的小世界中，只有我试着转向你。”
OK. And you just told her this answer like this?
好吧。你就是这样把这个答案告诉她的？
Yeah.
是的。
And she?
那她呢？
I mean, she would pass in and out of being interested in it. And at the end of it, she was just like, oh, yeah. OK.
我是说，她一会儿感兴趣，一会儿又不感兴趣。最后，她只是说，哦，是的。好吧。
And I'm like, all right, well, I mean, do you see what I'm saying about time? It's a measurement of change. It's an arbitrary human construct, but not, but it feels different. It's this phenomenon. She's like, yeah, yeah, OK.
我说，好，好吧，我是说，你明白我关于时间的意思吗？它是一个衡量变化的尺度。它是一个任意的人类构造，或者不是，但感觉很不同。它是一种现象。她说，是的，是的，好吧。
I was like, oh. Well, this isn't really exactly what I wanted.
我说，哦。好吧，这不太是我想要的。
That's not what you wanted because you were like, oh, this is kind of boring?
那不是你想要的，因为你觉得这很无聊？
Yeah.
是的。
Rosie has a pixie cut and a cheeky grin. She gave her dad the 50 questions three years ago. She's 12 now. He's been working on getting her answers, but he's only gone through 2/3 of them because it takes him so long to cobble together a response. What I found out talking to Rosie is she didn't even really care about the answers to these questions.
罗西留着精灵短发，笑容灿烂。她三年前给了她爸爸那50个问题。她现在12岁了。他一直在努力回答，但只完成了三分之二，因为他拼凑一个回答需要太久。我从罗西那里了解到，她根本不在乎这些问题的答案。
Questions that I thought that would take him a long time to answer, because at the time I really just wanted to talk to him.
我以为他需要很长时间才能回答的问题，因为当时我只是想和他说话。
It all started when she first moved to New York City. Before then, she'd been living with her mom and grandparents most of the week. But then her grandpa, who she was really close to, died, and she had to move in with her dad during the week instead. At the same time, she started at a new school, where the kids either ignored or bullied her, and she felt lost. One day, she came home from school and decided she needed to do something about it.
这一切始于她刚搬到纽约市时。在那之前，她大部分时间都和妈妈及祖父母住在一起。但后来她非常亲近的祖父去世了，她不得不工作日搬去和爸爸住。同时，她进入了一所新学校，那里的孩子要么忽视她，要么欺负她，她感到很迷茫。一天，她放学回家，决定做点什么。
I was lonely. And I felt a little sad that nobody had really stepped out to say, oh, hey. It's gonna be OK. I'll be your friend. So that's when I really, really needed somebody to talk to.
我很孤独。我觉得有点难过，没有人真正走出来说，“嘿，会没事的。我会做你的朋友。”所以那是我真正、真正需要有人可以说话的时候。
So you didn't have anybody to talk to at school?
所以你在学校没人可说话？
No.
没有。
And then at home?
那在家呢？
No. That's really why I felt like, oh, this is my dad. He's a really important person. I love him very much. I really want to become closer with him. I wish there was something that I could do to make us closer.
没有。这就是为什么我觉得，哦，这是我的爸爸。他是一个非常重要的人。我非常爱他。我真的很想和他更亲近。我希望有什么事能让我们更亲近。
Did you feel like your dad wasn't paying enough attention to you?
你觉得你爸爸没给你足够的关注吗？
Yeah, a little bit. Or not a little bit. Yeah.
是的，一点点。或者说不止一点点。是的。
What was he doing instead?
他当时在做什么？
He was writing papers on his computer. And I knew at the time how important it was, but part of me still wished that-- like, put down all the screens. Put down everything else and just talk.
他在电脑上写论文。我知道那当时有多重要，但我内心的一部分还是希望——把屏幕都放下。把其他东西都放下，只管谈话。
So I wrote all the questions down, and they were big questions because I know my dad. And if it's a little question, he'll elaborate on it, and he'll make it a big deal. So if you times that by a big, complex question, that would be a huge talk.
所以我把问题都写下来了，它们都是些大问题，因为我了解我爸爸。如果是小问题，他会过度发挥，把它弄得大惊小怪。所以如果你把它乘以一个复杂的大问题，那就会是一次漫长的谈话。
Is it true that you weren't talking to her much at the time?
当时他真的没和你聊很多吗？
No, I think I was talking to her all the time. You know, I would tell it was time to get up and go to school. I would tell her that it was time to do her homework. I would tell her that she needed a new jacket. Yeah, I mean, I talked to you all the time.
不，我觉得我一直都在和她谈话。你知道，我会告诉她是时候起床去上学了。我会告诉她是时候做家庭作业了。我会告诉她她需要一件新夹克。是的，我是说，我一直都在跟你说话。
Maybe you're noticing the purely logistical nature of everything he mentioned? It certainly didn't get past Rosie.
也许你注意到了他提到的所有事情本质上都是后勤性的？罗西肯定也发现了。
I talked to you all the time.
我一直都在跟你说话。
Yeah, but to me, it's not really the same thing. So a conversation and talking are completely different things. Talking could be a range from, oh, hey, what's up? And conversation is you're deep in thought and you're looking, and you're making eye contact, and you're really enjoying the presence of somebody else.
是的，但对我来说，那不是一回事。谈话和说话是两码事。说话可能范围是“嘿，怎么了？”而谈话意味着你沉浸在思想中，你在注视，你在进行眼神交流，你真正享受另一个人的存在。
Rosie's a smart kid, yeah, but this is the thing I really admire about her. Matt was a single dad with two kids, going to school and trying to make the rent at the same time. Telling him to pay attention to her didn't cut it, so she figured out something else.
罗西是个聪明的孩子，是的，但这是我真正钦佩她的一点。马特是个单身父亲，带着两个孩子，还要上学，还要同时设法付房租。告诉他多关注她根本没用，所以她想出了别的办法。
I read this short story recently about a successful con man, whose motto was, "make them want to give you the thing you want to take." Rosie made her dad want to give her attention by making an opportunity to do what he loved-- ponder over life's big questions.
我最近读过一个短篇故事，关于一个成功的骗子，他的座右铭是“让他们想给你你想要夺走的东西”。罗西让爸爸想给她关注，通过创造一个机会去做他热爱的事——思考生命中的重大问题。
My dad was kind of hardshelled, I guess. And so it took a lot. I had to keep asking these questions and keep wondering. For me, it was just, I had to keep going and keep trying, and keep being this little bird that goes on your shoulder and is like, I am now your friend.
我爸爸有点硬壳，我想。所以这花了很多功夫。我不得不不停地问这些问题，不停地怀疑。对我来说，我必须坚持下去，不停尝试，不停地做那只落到你肩膀上的小鸟，心想：我现在是你的朋友了。
Do you feel like it taught him how to talk to you better?
你觉得这教会了他如何更好地和你谈话吗？
Yeah, definitely. Over the past three years, we've really worked on having actual conversations, than him just answering questions from me because we practice it.
是的，绝对。在过去三年里，我们真正致力于进行实际的谈话，而不是他只是回答我的问题，因为我们练习了。
Rosie never knew that her dad spent months and months writing down each answer. Matt only told her when I started working on this story. And she said she felt like, what? Are you kidding me?
罗西从未知道爸爸花了几个月的时间写下每个答案。马特只有在我开始制作这个故事时才告诉她。她说她觉得，什么？你在开玩笑吗？
I had no idea that he was doing all these things, and it was just a big surprise for me. If I could, I would definitely just say, forget the questions. I just wanna talk.
我根本不知道他在做这些事，这对我来说是个大惊喜。如果可以，我肯定会说，忘了那些问题吧。我只想说话。
So you're like, well, you don't even have to go through all that trouble.
所以你的意思是，好吧，你甚至不需要花那么多功夫。
Yeah.
是的。
Just hang out.
只要待在一起。
Yeah.
是的。
Rosie said this to her dad when she found out, and it really threw him for a loop.
罗西发现这一点时对她爸爸说了这句话，这让他深受触动。
Yeah, it was a complete waste of time. I mean, what a complete waste of time to come up with these big, extensive projects that are definitely less important to them than just listening to them.
是的，这完全是浪费时间。我是说，搞出这些巨大的、广泛的工程简直是浪费时间，它们对她们来说绝对不如倾听重要。
You know, what is time? Why? Explain. Well, I can tell you what I don't want time to be. I don't want time to be something where I am just figuring out that I need to shut up and make some time to listen to this little kid before it's too late.
你知道，什么是时间？为什么？解释一下。好吧，我可以告诉你我不想要时间是什么。我不想时间是我发现自己需要闭嘴，抽出时间来听这个小孩子说话，直到太晚了为止。
Rosie really started asking the questions because she wanted to know that she wasn't alone and that everything was going to be OK. Now she enjoys hearing the answers because they remind her that that's true. That's why one of her favorite answers is the ending of, Time? Why? Explain. The part about all of the planets turning around themselves, and in the middle of it, Matt turning towards Rosie.
罗西开始问这些问题确实是因为她想知道自己并不孤独，一切都会好起来。现在她很喜欢听答案，因为它们提醒她这是真的。这就是为什么她最喜欢的答案之一是“时间？为什么？解释一下”的结尾。那是关于所有行星围绕自身旋转，而在其中，马特转向罗西的部分。
One of the main meanings of that is, even though everything is happening around you, he just wants to know about me a little more, I guess. And a thing that I really like about that is because he just uses these sentences that make me happy when I read them.
其中主要含义之一是，尽管身边发生着这一切，他只是想多了解我一点。我真的很喜欢这一点，因为他用的那些句子读起来让我很开心。
You know, it's kinda funny, when he read this to me he sort of choked up a little bit.
你知道，这有点好笑，当他读给我听时，他有点哽咽。
Yeah. He likes to be a one expression person. But when he reads stuff like this he gets all emotional. In the car ride here he was like, oh, I love you so much. And he was tearing up looking out the window, so--
是的。他喜欢做一个表情不动的人。但当他读这样的东西时，他会变得很情绪化。在开车来的路上，他说，哦，我太爱你了。他看着窗外流泪了，所以……
You look so happy about that.
你看起来因为这个很高兴。
Yeah. Pretty great.
是的。相当棒。
So people have been asking these big important questions like, why are we here, what is life, for forever. And do you think that the real big reason why we ask it is to have a reason to talk to each other?
所以人们永远都在问这些重大的重要问题，比如我们为什么在这里，什么是生命。你认为我们问这些问题的真正重大原因是有一个理由互相谈话吗？
No, I think that philosophers actually really do wonder about these things. And they don't use it so that they could talk to their dads more. They use it because they really wonder about these things and they want to know everything. But for my personal use, yes. That's exactly it.
不，我认为哲学家们确实真的在思考这些事。他们不用这个作为多和爸爸谈话的理由。他们用它是因为他们确实在思考这些事，想知道一切。但就我个人而言，是的。就是这样。
Matt does still want to keep answering Rosie's questions for her. But as for the hardest question, what is love, I don't think Rosie needs her dad to explain that to her anymore. She gets it.
马特确实还想继续为罗西解答问题。但至于最难的问题，什么是爱，我觉得罗西不需要她爸爸再给她解释了。她懂了。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program.
斯蒂芬妮·福是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩制作。我们的员工包括艾莉丝·伯格森、苏珊·伯顿、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹杰菲尔德、凯伦·达芬、斯蒂芬妮·福、金伯利·亨德森、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和戴安·吴。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can help SETI, the Search for Extraterrestrial Intelligence, sort through its data, looking for extraterrestrials terrestrials, with your own computer with software that runs in the background on your computer. To get that software, just google SETI@home.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。你可以通过你自己的电脑，用在后台运行的软件，帮助SETI（地外文明搜寻中心）整理数据，寻找外星人。要获取该软件，只需谷歌搜索SETI@home。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Back when we first started the radio show, he told me I could have full editorial control. He would never tell me what to say.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。当我们刚开始做广播节目时，他告诉我我可以拥有完整的编辑控制权。他永远不会告诉我该说什么。
You can use the words you want. You can use your body.
你可以用你想要的词汇。你可以用你的身体语言。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。